application is above but modified to
such an extent as considered appropriate
to satisfy any of those relevant
representations and promote licensing
objectives
or you can reject the application again
um we've seen that the applicant
originally applied
for licensable activities
um until midnight following the
consultation period
and conditions were agreed and
an amendment in terms of the timings of
the application
was also agreed uh so therefore
we see this application is just for the
supply of alcohol
both on and off the off the premises um
and opening hours um
from 11 a.m till 2300 hours
once again that application was
correctly made all procedures were
followed
it's attached as appendix b and the
photograph of the blue notice newspaper
advertiser is attached as appendix b and
we can see in the operating schedule um
there's a there's a
a list of conditions that are provided
for 3.2
onwards and which are measures that were
included in the application
and then from 3.11 onwards are the
conditions that were agreed with the
environmental health officer
a similar overlap to bring to your
attention once again
3.11 and should not apply for this
committee because of the
deregulation in in the entertainment
the uh at 3.17 we had further conditions
that were agreed with the trading
standards officer
and that relates to cctv and staff
training and
age verification scheme
the um
in terms of the consultation i um
all the responsible authorities were
included of the consultees identified we
did receive a representation from the
environmental health officer
um but following the discussions the
applicant
had with the environmental health
officer conditions and amended timelines
were agreed and that representation was
subsequently withdrawn
a copy of that representation um
there was also a representation that was
included from an other person as the
license in that term and that's attached
as appendix c
once again a copy of the report and all
representations uh received have been
sent
to the applicant thank you chair
okay kieran thanks very much so
everybody clear
about the application what we're
deciding
and um obviously very similar to the
previous one
it's like different location and some
minor changes
so if anybody hadn't got any questions
of the licensing officer
no okay can then i ask the applicant to
to speak to this application for 164a
barton road
yeah and very similar to
all the concerns previously we've just
discussed um
the overriding thing would be upstairs
predominantly going to be a restaurant
providing
indian style fast food
business partner in raj who's
not here today and he
he previously had a restaurant near us
down the road and he was providing some
food for us
[Music]
um
[Music]
where that came from
you know it's probably gonna be
difficult to restaurant really
we're obviously much keener for them to
be drinking downstairs to be honest with
you
but we
again it's a bit of a bad line it's a
likeness indian restaurant is that
correct
it's a you see yeah like an indian tapas
restaurant right okay
um get the picture yeah
all right um i mean obviously
it's a little bit nearer the residents
in uh
pinpoint court than than the other one
do you see any
any any problems arise arising from that
any increased
difficulties because you know people
leaving the building or
or again the obviously the issue was
people going going to
go outside to smoke yeah well we
will obviously because we we've got the
two premises
um again we'll we'll make sure that
smoking doesn't make the area
is outside the main
outside 166 but
with it being a restaurant it won't be
it won't be generating as much
noise and again we've even discussed
uh where the
extractor hood
so we're already in discussions about
about movies
i'm not saying but the same applies
from what we were discussing earlier
it generally won't be
annoying
yeah it was a bit bit difficult so
that you will you will be doing a noise
management plan for this premises
yes yes uh he's doing both both premises
we should have that next week and that
will include
the extract extractor hud for the
kitchen
yeah we've i've already took advice from
him uh from
from the couple of meetings we've
already had uh prior to that
we started
okay thank you does any of the committee
have any questions for mr lee
hey if i could just come in then uh
obviously being a restaurant and uh
kind of food that's likely to be cooked
there i mean
then you've got extractor funds where
the extractor fans actually located
in terms of that diagram you got there
um
in the in the kitchen area as you come
up the stairs the kitchen's going to be
from external wall so it's an extractive
fan
the way we're going to do it is it's
going to caught into the
roof space and across the building
from the doctor
is the extractor fan going to extend
above the roof
the exhaust sort of thing it's going to
go out
through the other side
the other side of the building yes which
side is that then i mean
in terms of that diagram you've got
there on the on the on the papers
whereabouts is it on that dirt
um well i don't think you can see where
the roof space is but
it'll be coming across across the roof
[Music]
this is a different orientation than the
other one isn't it because
the front door is at the top at the top
of the
diagram right
so that this is first floor obviously
yeah yeah
right but it's 180 degrees
disposed from the other diagram just so
we're clear
can the license officer explain where
that is
going yeah no i i i can't help
you with with that i'm afraid i think
it's gonna come with it from the
applicant i think
i'm sorry let me just get it in front of
me quickly
yeah i'm just as confused
yeah so
so the top of the stairs there
is that that that's going to be
where that emergency exit is on the
other side of the room
yeah is that the front it's not the main
road there
no no it died
you go up the stairs straight away yeah
that's right
so the main road is where the stairs are
right
yeah so somebody at the top of the
stairs in the kitchen
will be an extractor hood on pinto
courtrooms alongside them
this paragraph with it um and
barton road is at the front where the
stairs are
so the extractor fan will run through
the roof space
across the building and pop out
near where that emergency exit was
yeah i'm trying to get orientation right
there
do you mean the emergency exit on the
right hand side of the drawing yeah
let's say the dusting will be in the
root space so i
on that side is that where the 166 is on
that side which side is 166 on
or to the right of that the right yeah
yeah
okay so the extractor fan is going to go
across
the stage it's to the right yeah yeah
so come through the roof yeah the roof
space
looking from the front to the left
yeah okay i'm not sure if that will work
but uh i'm not
technical on that but without i've
actually had
somebody who scores extractor funds
here yeah
yeah yeah that was the main thing though
so the residents there would not be
effective
i mean i would be nice smiles but you
don't want them constantly being
inundated with
uh strong smiles yeah yeah i think yeah
yeah the other thing is what what number
of people are you intending to be
employed there you know and then when a
normal operational level
uh you know all things being normal what
kind of
number of staff are going to be at these
premises
um in relation to what's there so there
would be somebody
behind
i'd say between five and six yeah
okay and on the i mean i never want to
go to back one the other one
the other one but one six six would be
didn't ask that question before that it
would be
it would be similar sort of uh to what
we have usually
in normal circumstances
[Music]
as well the fact that you know staff
members do tend to smoke as well you
know
quite a few it would be probably using
the the back entrance or the uh
some other exit though they wouldn't uh
be also they would also avoid having to
be on the
printful court side yeah yeah but they'd
have to provide
okay barry do you have any questions for
the applicant
you did oh he removed
barry oh sorry yeah
sorry the uh the emergency exit on the
right hand side of the drawing
does that then come out onto like a
metal fire escape or something is that
what
it currently comes out onto the um to
the roof space
the extension is flat roof our intention
is to
get some handrails up there there's
actually steps
down in
our intentions to do some work on that
flat road
and put some handrails up because there
is an existing stair
over the gun in that case we have
the property
at the bottom of the drawing there's
possibly a pair of french windows or
something
are they just windows do they open onto
a flat roof hole yeah
i think i mean i visited the sip club a
few times and in certain the warmer
weather yeah
those are the windows that were open and
i thought they they'll help them to a
flat roof as well do they
that's right yeah yeah yeah but i'd be a
bit worried that people
the staff as dylan said if people are
going for smoke they might be tempted to
the flats where the residents have
complained they're they're off to the
bottom left-hand side are they of the
air
so that that would be my concern a bit
if people were going to go out onto the
flat roofs mainly we have no intention
because because we're using the seller
from downstairs
uh upstairs as well
there's no need to carry
yeah okay thanks chair thank you
all right do any any of the officers
have any questions for the
applicant no
no okay charlotte do you have any
questions for
the applicant no no questions just to
say that i'm
uh relieved that the extraction is going
to be on the opposite side because i
hang my laundry out on the balcony
and would really not fancy curried
smelling underwear in any way shape or
form
and additionally to say that um
we also had concerns about if they were
going to use the flat roof
because some of the residents were
worried the view from that is basically
into their living rooms
and they would feel that they felt that
that was incredibly intrusive
um it wouldn't affect me i'm on the
corner it doesn't
bother me at all but the other residents
have brought that up
yeah with no intention of using it
okay thank you um charlotte it's your
turn to speak if you want to
add anything else to that
there's not much else to add i mean the
issues
we already highlighted in the previous
discussion
around noise around smoking around
people coming in and out
and leaving in taxis because if you're
coming to eat you're still gonna drink
and you're still gonna have no volume
control
so similar issues thank you um
right to see mr lee do you have any
questions for the representative
at all um no because
like it like tells you that we probably
discuss most of the issues and
hopefully we've
solved most of the issues with monster
management therapy
once in place it's a document you can
see
yeah really to add to it
okay thank you charlotte do you wish to
say a few words in summary
about the representation before we close
um happily i mean as i've mentioned
the um issues around extraction and the
flat roof space have been cleared up so
that's great um
we know that the timings are going to be
similar to the other site so that's
a positive step it's just making sure
that
we have and it's not just me but we have
some way of
of highlighting any issues that come up
yeah okay thank you um and mr lee would
you like
to summarize um
it's not a great deal to summarize
the um charlie's got my contact details
anybody in that building nine contact
details so
uh we're hoping to be good neighbors and
okay thank you we tend to be repeating
ourselves a lot tonight
anyway i think we'll ask if we can go
into the breakout rooms and then
and then we'll make